Okay, so the first module that I'm sharing with you here is truly understanding
this tool here
and the power and the feature of it. And so on here you'll see two things when
you're looking
at the 15 minute timeframe especially. You'll see directional bias and you'll
see market structure.
Now on one hand it's easy to get a little bit confused on what the actual
difference between
the two is. I mean, isn't directional bias the same as market structure? Don't
you derive your
directional bias based off of market structure? And potentially yes, unless you
know something
that I'm going to share with you now. So in this case, we have a weekly and we
have a daily
directional bias. And you can see here that actually both of them are bearish,
but the 15
minute and four hour timeframe are actually bullish in terms of their actual
structure.
As you can see, you know, swing low, change of character, swing high. And also,
I'm in a short
position literally right now that I've recently closed partials of these lows
in. So structure
is bullish, but I'm shorting and the daily bias and the weekly bias is bearish.
And also on my
live trading sessions yesterday with my live trading students and some of the,
and actually
some of the prosperity school members, I'm telling them literally yesterday
that this is the level
that I'm expecting a lot of prices from. Now, why, why is that? That's what I
kind of want
to share with you today. And that's kind of what the by the daily bias the
weekly bias is about.
So I'm going to insert a full kind of like 15 minute video that I've created
for you
on the daily bias that just basically explains what it is. In a very simple
shell, the daily
bias is really simple. It's based off of the logic that if a, if today's daily
candle closes
below the previous day's candle, the next day's price action is going to be
bearish.
And this isn't random opinion. In fact, let me back it up with the data.
So this is for 2721 days in which there was an actual bearish close. And this
data that I have
collected here is over 5,469 days. And so what is that 5,469 divided by 365? So
this is actually
over 15 years of data. And so as you can see, we don't play around around here.
We're not the type of people that are going to give you some vague nonsense and
claim that
it works. Now, this is 15 years of historical data that we have proven this.
And what we have
found is that on 67% of the time in which the current days candle closes below
the previous
days low, the next day trades bearish below the previous days low. And so if
you look,
for example, let's go to the daily right now and kind of just explain this,
right? So what we can see
is in theory, what this would indicate. So we can come out of replay for a
second.
Well, this specific concept would indicate that this day's candle closed below
the previous days
low, correct? And so we are indicating that the next day will be a bearish day
that trades below
this low down here. Now, there's also more power to this when you understand
that before it does
that, what we're looking for is a retracement and then the sell off. And so if
you play the next day,
you can see we open, we trade higher, and then we trade lower, perfect sell off
opportunities.
So that's that specific one. And there are a bunch of different logic, right?
So for example,
if, and the reason that it says on our indicator why we are bearish today,
right? That is because if price wicks above the previous day's high,
wicks above the previous day's high and closes inside of that range, there is
again a 67% likelihood
that price will trade down into the low of that day. And you come into today.
And so already,
I have been in shorts or been looking at shorts from this area of price, right,
which is why if you look at where I am, I am already in shorts from here.
This is my London set up, which is also again, like I said, a lot of the
members are
in this exact trade as well. And I'm holding some partial down to this low.
So that's just one of the points of logic. There is a lot more than that.
All right. It also indicates again, so this is daily wins. So it also indicates
the opposite,
which is if we close above on the daily, we are expecting the next day. So
again, 67%.
Accuracy. So this is true with a 67% accuracy of the last 50 years of price.
Also, the exact same thing happens for the weekly, right? The weekly also has
the same thing.
We have noticed that there is actually a 68% level of accuracy with on the
weekly. So the exact
same thing, if we look at the weekly, right, the exact same thing. So you can
see right here,
right? This is the previous week's candle. This previous week's candle has
closed
below this candle. And so coming into this week, the expectation for price has
been,
we will open, we will trade higher, and then we will trade lower. And the
target that we
should expect with a 68% likelihood over the period of many, many, many years,
that's a 68% likelihood, which is a very high probability that that's going to
play out.
And so I'm going to add in now a little bit of a snippet that will take this a
little bit further,
so you can see it really kind of play out in action on how I'm reading this.
And yeah, that is what this is. So when you're in price,
and you see that the market structure direction is one thing. So it will show
you the market structure
direction is on the 15 minute is bullish on the four hour, it is bullish, but
both the daily and
weekly directional biases are both bearish, right? And so you can kind of get
where I'm going
with this. This is one of the invalidation methods of structure sometimes,
which I'll break down
later. So I'll give you a little bit more context now and so kind of how that
works and I'll show
you it in action working really well. And that should conclude this and you
show, you know,
proceed to do with this information as you deem necessary. So we'll start with
where we're at,
right? Monday the 13th of October, you can see this is a bearish daily candle
and it's honestly
very indecisive. So a candle like this and a day like this doesn't really give
us any information,
we don't actually know what the next day is going to do. We're kind of in a
consolidation phase.
What I will say is that the market is always ranging from consolidation to
expansion back
into consolidation, back into either expansion in the buy side or expansion
towards the sell side.
So we know we're going to be gearing up for a direct move, we just need to see
the direction
of that. And so the next daily candle prints like this. Now, very, very
important details,
notice, right, that this is a bullish daily candle. That's the first thing. I
want you to see here
that we open down here, we wick below the low and then we close toward the buy
side of this daily
candle, right? So we have a bullish daily candle that has wicked below the
previous day's low
and closed back inside of the range already that immediately tells me tomorrow
is a bullish day.
And on this candle, what we can see is that we open down here, we have a very
bullish aggression
and we're closing toward the buy side. Again, above the previous day's high,
closed toward the buy side, it tells me again that tomorrow is going to be a
bullish day,
or at least we are going to get a bullish expansion. Again, another bullish
move,
we've broken above that previous day's high and we've closed up in here. Again,
that tells me
that we're definitely going to be targeting this day's high and we're going to
be essentially
ending up higher than the previous day's high. Okay, now what we see here is a
bearish daily
candle, right? But we were expecting higher prices. This daily candle right
here, and if I
just focus on just this daily candle and let's say we drop down to a one hour
time frame,
right? Here we are one hour time frame. In fact, let's go to a 15 minute real
quick. So
the day opens here, right? This is where the daily candle opens. It opens on
the and this
is the daily candle. So this is the daily closed daily open. So it opens here.
So you see that we
actually open first going bullish. So the bias was higher prices. We got those
higher prices and
then eventually price sells off. And that's what that daily candle looks like.
So if we go back to
the daily time frame, what this now tells me is that tomorrow is going to be
bearish,
because we've hit these highs, we've wicked above this high. So you're looking
for a wick above
and a close back inside bearish. That tells me that tomorrow is going to be
bearish. But also,
what do we have, right? This is step number two again. It's just reading your
draw on liquidity.
You can see here that we have this bullish fair value gap. So tomorrow then I
can already anticipate
there's a good chance that we're going to trade bearish and we're going to
enter into
ward this fair value gap, right? That's what I have in mind. And again, I'm
just want to predict
the next daily candle. And again, what do you see? The next daily candle is
another bearish candle,
right? We've closed below and we've ended up inside this level. Now the key
here is the power
of three, right? Many people, you've probably heard them talk about the power
of three.
The power of three is essentially a manipulation and distribution, right? So
you have, you know,
a range bound period like this. And then you have a manipulation. And then you
have a distribution.
That's kind of the power of three. And it essentially states that before price
will trade lower,
it will first trade higher. You can see that time and time again in this model,
right? So you can
see here we've broken and closed below this low. But notice that beforehand,
there's a good chance
that we actually come higher and then lower. What I want to be is I want to be
a seller at this
level of price. So if we do the same thing again, if we square off this price
action and we go to
yesterday's open and close. So here's the fair value gap down here. If we
remove this for now and
we find the open of this day is here 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time. Notice that
we are expecting
bearish price. But before we get the sell off, we get first a bullish move,
right? That's the
manipulation of the day and then the sell off. So I, someone who wants to be a
seller,
I'm waiting for that manipulation. And then I'm looking to sell after that
manipulation occurs.
It's always the same thing again. We'll always get the pullback and
continuation. That's the
same thing, right? It's like before you trade lower, if you have a bearish
daily bias, the next day
you're expecting, you know, a manipulation before the continuation lower. And
you want to basically
be selling here. If this is the daily open, first we're going to manipulate
toward the buy side,
then we're going to sell off toward the sell side. And that is essentially what
we're seeing.
And so for me now, what I would be looking at for the next level is first and
foremost,
let's also talk about more drawn liquidity. What do we have here? I equal lows
down here at these
lows. Also, if you look down here, we have this overlapping fair value gap.
Very, very
interesting area, an area that I was talking to my students with for a couple
of weeks,
saying that ultimately we will probably end up trading at this level. Equal
lows down here and
an overlapping fair value gap. So we also have this as a draw on liquidity,
right, or a bias to trade
towards. Again, looking at the next daily candle, what do you think is going to
happen? For me,
I'm indicating more likely that we're going to get more bearish price action,
right, another
bearish continuation. What happens? We open, we first have a run toward the buy
side, and then we
have the sell off doing what again, that same pattern, right? We have our open
manipulation
and move toward the sell side, right? And now what have we done? Now we've
closed over that
fair value gap. So we've inverted that fair value gap, which then also becomes
another area of
interest for me. So if I was to let's say be a seller now, right, an interest
in move could be a
retracement into here and then a continuation out of here, right? This is how
you're building
daily bias centrally. Now notice what happens here. This time we actually have
a bullish daily candle
and notice that we've wicked below this low and closed back inside. That to me
is typically
signed of a reversal, right? So what I would now be looking for is now we have
this bullish
fair value gap in here, which is also overlapping. Now I would be expecting the
next day to trade
higher above this previous day's high and into this level right here, right?
Simple as that. That's
what I would be looking for. And what you notice is on this specific day, we
actually don't get that.
So we do get the open, we do get the manipulation and we do start getting the
momentum. So definitely
you could have been in a trade at these lows. And again, if I open up the 15
minute timeframe,
which is my primary timeframe for direction, you'll notice what market opens,
we have the bearish
manipulation, right? Even look at the structure on the 15 minute timeframe, we
were very bearish.
Now we've shifted bullish, right? Which is yesterday's manipulation and close
above the high.
And now we're selling off again, longs accumulated in this New York session,
and you're just holding
them ready for the next day, we're probably going to end up in this level. So
it's the same thing,
right? Just because we haven't fulfilled the prophecy yet, we've still been
able to probably
execute long positions in this area. And again, we'll go back to the daily,
right? We've still
anticipated bullish price action for that day after the manipulation, right? So
anytime that I have
a bias to go higher, I first want it to go lower before it goes higher. And I
want to try to buy
in this level. So this day, what would I be expecting a continuation higher
above these two highs? And
that's what happens, right? We get that move, we open, we pull back and we
continue trading higher.
Now what we've done is now we've come back into this bearish order block, you
can use this level,
you can use this candle regardless. And we've had quite an aggressive reaction
from it. But notice,
we have actually closed above the previous day's high. So what this tells me is
there is a lower
level of conviction, meaning the next day is a day where it could go higher,
but it also could go
lower. So you keep those things in mind. But ultimately, it's a bullish candle.
So you'd be
expecting probably a continuation, right, which is what we get. We get the open
, low, high, close.
So again, it's the same thing. Price is trading higher, but before it's trading
higher,
it's opening, coming down, and then trading higher and then closing here, right
? And so you'll get in
the open, low, high, close. That's what that is. So again, you're accumulating
long positions in
these levels based off of just the daily candle. It's literally that simple. So
for this day now,
what we can see is we have a bullish candle, but we have wicked above this high
and closed back
inside of the range. This tells me that this could be a reversal, but it could
also be a continuation.
Again, there is a little bit less clarity on the situation. You're not going to
get every
single day absolutely correct. That's not the game of trading. The game of
trading is probabilities.
So the next day, we get that continuation again, right, higher prices. But
notice that the momentum
is starting to kind of fade away. So again, what do we get? A wick above the
high and close back
inside. So again, this for me now, when you're wicking above this high closing
inside the range,
it's usually indication of a reversal, but you could also continue before you
reverse, right?
So a lot of the times when you get these types of candles, where they're wick
heavy, you'll probably
see before a reversal, maybe a sweep of a high. If we look at this level, okay,
so the next day,
we don't get that. We get a very aggressive sell off, right? So we close below
that previous day's low,
we open here, we manipulate toward the buy side, we have an aggressive sell off
,
we close below the previous day's low. For me now, the next day is simple. We
have equal lows
down here. Again, that number two draw on liquidity, that bias, we have those
equal lows as a draw
on liquidity, we have these equal lows as a draw on liquidity. So what am I
looking for today? This
is a very obvious day. I'm expecting a pullback and then a sell off, right?
That's the daily bias.
What happens? Again, we can go into the 15 minute timeframe. You can see we
open, we put in the high,
and then we sell off aggressively, right? Perfect opportunity, perfect day to
begin
into short positions, right? Where does the market open? Market opens here at 5
p.m. What happens?
We pull back into this area, and then we sell off. In London session, we're
good to be selling.
New York session, sell continuation, right? Same thing all based off of the
previous day's
candle. That's it. Just the daily bias, right? So the market, we open, we put
in the high,
and then we sell off aggressively. So what do you think I'm expecting today?
Well,
now we've taken out this draw on liquidity, but we still have this one down
here. We've closed
below that low, right? Aggressive close below that low, and now I'm expecting
what? A pullback
and continuation again. What happens? Open pullback continuation, right?
Perfect mitigation of this
previous day's low. What do I'm expecting again? Well, now we've taken the draw
on liquidity.
We've hit the draw on liquidity, right? We've also hit into this favor. But we
have a gain
closed below that low, and so I am most likely expecting lower prices for this
day. And again,
what do we get? We get open pullback, sell off. So again, this is where you
want to be looking at
it. Before this day even opens, you're expecting, okay, today I'm going to be
bearish. We're going
to have a bullish pullback. I'm going to sell, go lower. Next day, bearish
bullish pullback.
I'm going to be a seller, go lower. Next day, bearish bullish pullback. I'm a
seller, go lower,
right? On this day now, notice that the momentum is starting to get a little
bit slower. Now we're
inside of our draw on liquidity. Now you can start adding that into the context
of slowing down
and expect that maybe at some point we'll start to get a reversal. But still,
for this specific day,
my next daily bias would still be bearish. Why? Because we've closed below the
previous day slow.
Again, what do we get? Open pullback, sell off. Again, you're just a seller in
this market.
The next day, what am I expecting? Another sell. Now notice that we do get the
sell, right? So we
do trade below this low, which was the goal of the day. But now notice what
happens. We have a
bullish day, and we actually have a wick below previous day's low and a closed
back inside.
This for me is literally a SOS that we are about to reverse. The market is
going to now trade bullish,
and it's very simple. Now you look and you see, okay, well, we actually have
number one point of
interest that we're trading out of. Secondly, we have a bullish fair value gap
here. We have a
bullish fair value gap here, right? So now we have these higher time frame
areas of interest or
draws on liquidity that we're expecting price to trade back into. So now what
do you think I'm
looking for? Now today, I'm expecting to be a buyer, price is going to pull
back in here,
and then shoot off up here, pull back in here and shoot off in here, right?
So what does the next day do? The next day, we open here a very small pullback
and a very
aggressive bullish candle. Well, now what do you think I'm expecting price to
do on this next day?
Again, I'm expecting that we're going to have another bullish day, right? A
little pullback
and continuation. What happens? Market opens, we sell off and we go higher,
right? 15 minute
timeframe. What does that look like? Again, perfect opportunity to get longs,
right?
The market opens here. Market opens, we sell off, London opens, right? There's
a perfect
entry opportunity in here. We traded long on this position. Market booms
towards the upside,
which is expected. So they get the manipulation, you wait for the manipulation,
you wait for the
confirmation on the lower timeframes, and then you execute and long, right? It
's so simple. It
It literally works every day.